[Music]
all right would you want to watch I want
to watch the video of the CEO oh yeah
being like the
something like she took a four and a
half million dollar bonus that year but
then cut bonuses for employees yeah
questions came
can we stay motivated if we're not going
to get a bonus what can we do what can
we do some of them were nice and some of
them were not so nice so I'm going to
address this head-on oh head on
oh now I don't know how many of us have
experienced upsetting a passive
aggressive
person but ooh it's like this that right
there she like she just pulled
a desert eagle out of her pocket
some of them were not so nice so I'm
gonna address this head I'm gonna dress
this head on yeah
addicted supply chain none of us could
have predicted bank failures but what we
can do is stay in front of our customers
provide the best customer service we can
get our orders out our door treat each
other well be kind be respectful focus
on the future because it will be bright
stop asking why you can't have your
bonus
help the [__] customer yeah sell the
product
don't worry look forward look stop
looking at my six million dollar keep
your disgusting little eyes off of my
six million dollars look forward
and smile and smile don't smile at my
little statue right here look forward to
the future you poor piece of [__] that
thing is worth more than your house that
little statue right there don't look at
it look at the customer look forward
look at your email
this isn't fun for me it's not fun for
me to take away your bonus listen you're
gonna die someday We're not gonna be
here forever you're gonna die someday so
you might as well work okay
you might as well look forward
look to the Future
and focus on things you can't control
you can control your face control your
face yeah why are you crying yeah why
are you crying
why are you crying about my rent why are
you crying
what our time on Earth is limited right
so we might as well take that time okay
the time we do have the time we can
control and spend that time serving the
customer
[Laughter]
is going to get better so lead lead by
example treat people well talk to them
be kind and get after it don't ask about
what are we going to do if you don't get
a bonus get the damn 26 million dollars
spend your time and your effort thinking
about the 26 million dollars we need and
not thinking about what you're gonna do
if we don't get a bonus all right
can I get some commitment for that I
would appreciate
I had an old boss who said to me one
time you can visit pity City but you
can't live there so people leave pity CD
let's get it done
thank you have a great day
now if you're listening on audio
imagine hearing that
and then someone whose net worth is
probably 40 million dollars making a
nuclear hand gesture at you
Replay that moment that like oh
how do you make it to I don't how do you
make it to that level of leadership
and think that that kind of tone and
zoom is a good idea like how like dude
there's so
there's so many levels of separation
between what she did and what's
appropriate yeah
how did how do you do that like you all
right she has zero [__] empathy if
you're a CEO and you make millions of
dollars most good CEOs at least pretend
to care about people yeah like
exactly I'm
to care about people I'm just saying
like how are you that oblivious to the
fact that I mean you should care about
people but to know that your salary is
public information yeah
to know your employees can look up what
you made that year yeah and then to go
on a zoom and be like I'm gonna take the
tough love approach to the fact that
these people aren't getting bonuses yeah
and it's [__] crazy this has I need
my four million face yeah
written all over it man yeah look at
that [__] that's pure hatred seriously
just
the customer comes first
that's your you know you know that she
to whoever her partner is you know
whoever is at home with her you know
before she started that Zoom she was
like people do these days they just
don't want to work yeah they just don't
want to work I think I'm gonna go on
there and I'm gonna tell him how it is
yeah and I'm gonna tell him
you know what they need a wake-up call
yep
you know a little wake-up call and I'm
gonna take the tough love approach yo
and here we go I just want her son to be
like dude but what about like OBS screen
recording yeah yeah you know Mom this is
not not gonna look this is gonna blow up
on Tech talk please don't do this please
no no you guys you gen Z's and
Millennials you don't want to work
anymore no one knows what it's like to
actually put in some work yeah and then
when she when my dad Steve Herman Miller
started this company
my father used to slave away
beating other lower waged employees to
make these chairs with his bare hands he
used to have to hit employees with his
own Knuckles before they invented boxing
gloves
before they invented mouth guards that
was the only way to get the chairs made
was for Daddy Steven to go and punch
these stupid people right in their
[__] faces yeah and here we are and I
don't even punch the employees and now
though where's my bonus it's like you
don't even want to work
that was her kissing everyone's bonuses
goodbye
this is your bonus poof that's like this
is like the biggest like we have
McDonald's at home I also yeah I hate
the um
the the level the decibel of her voice
too it's like half it's like a whisper
yell yeah why the [__] is she doing that
it's just that please and thank you
thank you
yeah this is her this is her magnum opus
she got to this level she's a CEO of a
company and they're like Andy
you get the company where we need to be
this year you're gonna make yourself up
fat
and she was like this is the year yeah
this is the year where I burned down my
own kind yeah
I light them all on fire
and get my bonus
damn what when did she start
as CEO of Herman Miller
so she's been doing this for a while so
she comes with the furniture
last year she got moved to the CEO and
president of Miller Knoll which is the
parent company of Herman Miller damn so
she she must be like a beast a beast
she's just probably just inept at
dealing with people yeah that's why or
or is like so disconnected now from what
it means to be that's why she's great
for a big conglomerate like that yeah
they're like so Andy how do you feel
about human beings yeah
what are you talking about
well you know if you
maybe maybe you watch the elderly man
fall off of a train platform
in the middle of New York City what are
you doing in that situation
I don't know this man yeah and I don't
know this hypothetically you're putting
in front of me yeah are we talking
business or what like the people that
work at our stores those are people
yeah well you know I think they're very
lucky
yeah they're lucky to have a paycheck
they're lucky to be you know she went to
Harvard
keep her away from the zooms I would say
yeah you know yeah you know maybe do
like a chief people officer yeah stick
that person in there
that's an unfortunate acronym what CPO
yeah Chief people officer
and our CPO is coming in today
who
I'm not gonna say it but yeah I know it
yeah yeah yeah
yeah cool person officer yeah that's
what it is
I don't know like what what you're
supposed to do in that scenario if
you're the CEO of that company like do
you not that not for sure not that but
then you take your bonus and you want to
give it a sacrifice you're gonna be
honest I want to give a stab maybe you
want an improv like what you might have
done sure yeah yeah all right guys
it's me
the the father of this family
because we are a family and I love each
and every one of you like you were my
children
and love you so much and you know we are
a cohesive unit and we're working
towards
this ultimate goal of
solving the world's issue and need for
good
ergonomic Furniture right
chairs and such
and that being said the numbers we just
crunched them
I was back in the room with all the
little accountants and we were crunching
the numbers and they're not adding up
we're all over Excel we got the formulas
out each cell has a little formula and
things are let's just say red is coming
up a lot not a lot of green
but what was funny is when we took the
employee bonus column
and deleted it things turned green all
of a sudden
so that tells us
that as a family we're gonna have to
sacrifice
your bonuses
this year
keep in mind always keep in mind what
comes first
ergonomic chairs
that's the most important thing in the
world and you should dedicate your lives
to that purpose amen because the world
needs them and with that
amauri
I mean dad's right dad's right we um
we are building towards the goal of of
you know building the greatest ergonomic
chairs in society so yeah and by the way
if I get another sternly worded email
you're grounded
[Laughter]